why do youtube channels fail if you're a
youtube content creator who might be
struggling right now in this season of
creating content trying to figure out
this whole youtube thing and i'm so
excited for you to be a part of today's
episode where i bring my friend rob from
vidiq on and we're going to be talking
about the five main reasons that most
youtube channels are failing all that
and more coming up
[Music]
hey what's up my name is heather torres
from the think media team and you are
watching the youtube made simple show
where we help you overcome fear build
confidence and launch and grow a
successful youtube channel and today i
am joined by my friend rob over at vidiq
who just hit a million subscribers i'm
so excited for him to be on today and if
you don't know who rob is rob is vidiq's
youtube in residence meaning he's the
go-to guy when it comes to understanding
all the ins and outs of how vidiq and
how youtube really works he started out
on youtube in 2012 making videos about
tech before he joined the vid iq team
and today he is hard at work sharing
everything he's learned on the youtube
platform educating video creators on how
to grow their own channels and turn
their hobbies into a career just like
rob did in
2017. so let's bring rob up today hey
rob how you doing hello heather thank
you for having me on hello i like to
call uh this gang of people the think
media rights uh i may i just say ever as
somebody who goes live every single week
and always fumbles over their words that
was a perfect seamless introduction well
done to you well thank you i know it's
it's so hard i was thinking right before
we went live i'm like what is the hook
what am i doing how do i go every single
time rob i go live you always have to
like think through what i'm saying and
doing but i'm so excited hey congrats on
a million subscribers rob oh my goodness
yes i'm looking enviously at your gold
play button in the background but not
for very much longer apparently it's in
the mail as we speak i'm not tracking it
on google maps every other second i
promise you that's okay it's just gone
through uh las vegas no no no i'm not
paying attention to that we need to
focus on today's topic oh my goodness so
exciting what a huge milestone and today
we're going to talk about how youtube
channels fail and really a lot of this
is from you know you
coaching hundreds hundreds if not
thousands now of youtube content
creators through your live streams
through uh your coaching programs you
guys haven't been iq and all the things
you guys have available and i'm excited
because you've really boiled it down to
these five reasons we're going to talk
about it today and then we're going to
go into q a so if you have questions for
rob or myself just put four question
marks before and after uh in the live
chat if you're watching this live and if
you're on the replay and you're like
heather i have a question but i was at
work when you guys streamed still drop
that in the chat because that allows us
to go back and i'm in there answering
questions uh additionally to this live
stream so if you got a question on the
uh on the replay make sure to post that
down in the comments but rob we're gonna
lead into number one
which is that a channel only fails when
the creator quits let's jump into that
raw because you've got some insights
into what this actually means yeah i
think
you know we can talk about so many
things with youtube in terms of
click-through rate thumbnails audience
retention etc etc but ultimately at the
end of the day when you finished your
youtube things for the day it's a
mindset you know where are you on your
journey and a lot of people who are
getting frustrated and you know they
haven't got as many views or without
getting as many subscribers as they feel
they deserve that simply means that your
current expectations don't meet your
current reality and every creator at
some point has gone through this i mean
if you're in the live stream right now i
mean just raise a hand if you've ever
ever felt that moment of of struggle or
failure because boy myself heather sean
you know everyone i think mini team have
probably gone through those moments in
their youtube journeys and i know this
is a bit of a cliched example but i
think it's still the best one
mr beast who started his youtube channel
almost 10 years ago made
hundreds
hundreds of terrible videos
playing the same game everybody else was
he had a terrible camera
terrible audio
terrible editing terrible everything
but over the course of
you know tens of thousands of hours and
the dedication and commitment he's put
into his channel he's figured it out
pretty much better than anyone else on
the planet
but he started out exactly the same as
many of you and that is
just simply having the ability to make
videos having a camera having access to
the internet and a youtube account and
that's where we all start and i think
ultimately for a lot of us it's all in
our own minds and determination as to
where we end up and
um
you know for years mr b videos look like
this you know he's getting hundreds of
views per video and it took him years to
start to see that mountain climb and the
momentum build to where he's now getting
tens of millions of views every single
video and it it boils down to and i'm
wearing a shirt right now almost it's
create
learn
really importantly adapt and then repeat
don't just do the same thing over and
over again expecting different things to
happen and i'm sure some of you probably
familiar with this image are a similar
one where you're working very very hard
and you don't feel as if you're getting
the payoff from youtube
and many creators just don't stick
around long enough for that hard work to
to start paying off and i feel as if
there are far too many stories of people
who are really dedicated to their craft
working very hard for years and years
and years to become great content
content creators
and to finally find that success for it
to be a fluke or a whim of youtube's
algorithms
and you were just saying at the
beginning of this uh you know
we
vid iq recently hit
a million subscribers
but behind all of that there's been
a team uh who've worked with me travis
alexi jeff on the channel audits that
we've been working on for live streams
for years and i myself have been making
content for 10 years now i think
i know looking at my old channel and the
vid iq channel i've now done over 2 000
videos which sounds incredible
i've put tens of thousands of hours into
this to to reach this landmark but still
every day i have these moments of doubt
where i'm feeling like i'm failing
but i've never stopped and i keep
turning up i keep making content and i'm
still relentless just like everybody
who's listening to this or watching uh
this live stream right now
yeah it's so important too i mean when
you think about trying to be good at
anything it's so much about just putting
in the hours putting in the time and not
quitting and and rob i mean you've
probably gone through seasons right
where seasons where you had a bunch of
time where you could do this and seasons
where it was everything to get out of
bed and make that video talk about that
just a little bit too because i think
sometimes we think oh well yeah i mean
okay it's easy for him or yeah it's easy
for her but rob there's so many times
where it's really making the video is
the last thing that you want to do
yeah i actually i think the final point
covers that in quite a bit of detail so
if we're okay to hang on for that uh
yeah that's blind by you
yeah i guess
i mean right now i'm actually going
through this moment of uh an existential
crisis just as we've limped over a
million subscribers almost but we'll
come back to that because
so the next thing uh we want to talk
about is and now we're getting more into
the youtube side of things not
necessarily the mindset but the
the the creators approach to content and
again you know it's something you've
probably heard before uh but it is so
important and we want to try and
reinforce this point so many times it's
a lack of focus
we are talking now to
uh
hundreds of people but these are actual
human beings who value their time and
they want to get value from that time
and so when you're creating content for
the actual human beings that are
watching your content they have
particular tastes values and interests
i i think and this is kind of like a
personal opinion but
generally regarded as a an accepted
approach when you're first starting out
your youtube channel is to try and build
out
the the perfect avatar or who is your
ideal viewer now this is just a
rough example of how vid iq
creates that perfect viewer
at the moment they tend to be male 18 to
35 and i think that's because they have
predominantly a male presenter we're
looking to hopefully change that into
next year you know having a range of
presenters on the channel but that's
where we are right now
generally the creator tends to have been
on youtube for less than a year but they
have a serious side hustle which is
youtube and i want to potentially turn
that into
a money making
part of their life and so because of
that their current goal is somewhere
along the lines of a thousand
subscribers four thousand hours of watch
time money size however i don't know how
many times think media's been asked this
question but we're always asking
questions about four thousand hours of
watch time subscribers monetization and
so on it's it's that big thing youtube
is setting these requirements and when
creators start they see this as the
first big milestone to start earning
some money back from what they do but
they're frustrated with their progress
then maybe six months down the line and
they're getting 50 to 100 views per
video and it feels like they're the
goals that they've set are still far out
of reach
but they've likely had some success
somewhere they've had one video that's
really popped
or a couple of videos that have really
resonated with their audience but
they're probably not capitalized on it
you know they've not doubled down on
their successful content so they're
shown size of potential but they don't
know how to maximize it
and they've probably searched on youtube
how to get more views and subscribers
because that's the thing you search for
and
my responsible to that is always it's
not just about views and subscribers
this is so so much that goes into
those
i guess milestone targets that you're
searching for
so
roughly speaking there's a lot more
detail to this but roughly speaking that
would be an ideal viewer for vid iq and
because of that
our intention with every single video is
to make a video
for that person
i know it sounds like you're really
pigeonholing yourself and going after
one particular person
but
if you know who you're talking to
with exactly
with the exact same thoughts passions uh
values and so on
you're gonna hit that one target
audience but it's also gonna branch out
into people who have very similar
interests
so in terms of lack of focus that's
where i'm really trying to even nail
down our ideal persona even now i mean
uh heaven what about think media i guess
it's a little bit broader because you
have uh you have a lot of videos on on
camera tutorials but also youtube
education but i guess you're able to do
that with the larger team there at think
media
yeah i think the team dynamic definitely
helps and but but really rob even with
that i mean i want to make videos on
other things that don't necessarily give
us the exact um
it doesn't lead to the exact same uh
responses that we would want right like
i mean we want to start creating things
on thought leadership and and of of um
of other things but really it's like
keeping the focus on the main thing
being the main thing and i loved how you
said even just knowing what your avatar
is even coming to youtube for makes such
a huge difference and it will feel like
you're talking about the same thing over
and over and you are right rob like you
are talking about it over and over but
that newest video that you just posted
that is actually just a repeat of the
video you did four years ago but it was
the one with the thumbnail and the thing
that the person saw was their first
introduction to you and i think
sometimes we forget
that we need to be saying the same
things louder not oh i said that already
oh i did that already oh they already
know that no there are new people rob
you you just hit a million i mean you
guys are growing by thousands of
subscribers every single month that that
have never known you yet that are just
new to this and so for content creators
to just be remembering that the lack of
focus sometimes could also feel like
well i want to get to the new thing i
want to do the next thing because i've
already said it once
and you know think media uh now you want
you to branch out into fault leadership
you've earned that right you've built up
that audience
who are now
you know in love with your content and i
really really value what you have to say
about um youtube education but now i
want more from vid iq sorry i want more
from think media take me on a journey
elsewhere
so i think that's what um think media is
able to do and you're right as well in
terms of
when you present a concept
in six to 12 months time there's
probably new thoughts and ideas about
that concept but also you're a better
creator and you can tell whether it's a
story or you can educate people in a
much better way
we're actually now going into 2022.
uh we're redoing our videos on how to
get a thousand subscribers uh and how to
get 100 subscribers because we've
learned even us i've learned so much in
that time and we're all we're thinking
of trying to tell a story of how we went
from your very first subscriber to a
million subscriber and we're already
started making content uh on that series
um so yeah a lack of focus and continue
to reinfor uh re-enforce that focus all
of the time
yeah yeah
yeah and you know even well we're gonna
get to it just a little bit so let's go
into number three rob i have so many
comments about the last two that i'm
just so excited about but let's get into
the third one
[Laughter]
which is um front loading your efforts
talk about what that actually means as a
content creator and why channels are
failing because they're
not understanding this concept so
there's a lot that goes into each and
every video but the bottleneck
which everything must flow through are
the following things which sometimes get
neglected or in
more often than not get done at the last
minute or at the end
so
i'm going to use a quite a primitive
triangle here to show you the funnel of
what i mean here
whenever um
every video starts with an impression so
that's a title and a thumbnail
and you know hands up again who often
leaves this until the the last thing
that they do almost like they've
uploaded a video and now in the
optimization process they're really
starting to think a lot about the the
title and the thumbnail
which
is almost like a backwards way of
thinking about your content
if you think about how you're gonna get
somebody to click
and how to intrigue them with the title
that may help govern the flow
of the video that you're gonna make and
i've you know in the 2000 videos that
i've made i think 99.9 of them i've done
this backwards i've done a thumbnail in
the title in the opposite way so i'm
really trying to teach myself you know
as a creator who's got a million
subscribers i'm really trying to teach
myself you know re-engineer how i make
my content
and then
after every impression when you get a
click
all of those clicks are gonna at least
watch the first
five to ten seconds of your video
and so the video hook is absolutely
crucial i'm not going to talk about the
video intro i'm talking about the video
hook to keep them watching the content
so in terms of like your outros and the
core of your content of course those are
very important but everybody must go
through these
first three principles so let's think a
little bit more about uh titles uh we
could probably do a 24-hour livestream
on thumbnails
so i'm going to boil it down to two
things today
to really think about
however long you spend on your
thumbnails right now whether it's five
minutes 15 minutes half an hour just for
the next few thumbnails i want you to
spend twice as long making them to
really think about that postage size
image that you're making to encourage a
click
and then i'm trying to think of a better
way to phrase this but it hasn't quite
stuck in my head yet um but
however complex your thumbnails are
make them twice as simple or half as
complicated what i mean by that is let's
say your thumbnail has um
four people in it well the next one only
have two people in if it's got five
items in it maybe only have two items in
if it's got six
uh dominant colors
you know tailor it back down to three
dominant colors
because um this is thanks to uh one of
the videos i watched on think media
actually haven't ever nolan made a video
about um how netflix research
has recently shown that users spend on
average just 1.8 seconds
looking at a thumbnail which is
essentially this
and that's it that's how long you get
somebody looking at your thumbnails
they need to make sense in 1.8 seconds
so just think about that when you're
designing how complex it is
titles
um there are several things that you
want to think about to make sure that
the title
helps with a thumbnail uh and that is
relatively short if you're trying to
promote uh an emotional response out of
a human being remember these titles have
been read by humans
don't
think of a title as something that you
just stuff keywords into and that's
going to help youtube make it more
searchable
somebody
may be looking at your title and
somebody may be clicking on it try to
avoid repetition you know just including
the title in the thumbnail vice versa
the best titles actually complement or
marry up to the thumbnails somebody sees
a thumbnail they then look at the title
and that's the final moment of intrigue
before they click and these are all
things that you will learn over time
so again these are all
very i guess
broad strokes
looks at titles and think media
certainly got some excellent videos on
on titles and thumbnails specifically
the video hook
i'm sure you are relatively familiar
with this type of graph your audience
retention and it looks like a hockey
stick
and if you fail to hook a viewer at the
beginning of a video then you'll end up
with what we can see here
you know thousands sometimes millions of
people saw your thumbnail but then 15
minutes into that video
three percent of the people who clicked
on that thumbnail are still watching
which just
it's not good use of your time like from
i would say
30 seconds into this video you've
already lost a third of your audience so
fix
this
part first the video hook
for example let's say we were going to
do a video hook if this live stream uh
was a video on demand
instead of doing an intro which sounds
something along the lines of hi guys
welcome to my channel if you're new here
welcome to fit media we're going to
educate people on how to go to youtube
channels
make sure to subscribe etc etc etc think
about a video hook which might be
something along the lines of
this
the reason you fail at youtube is
because you suck at making videos but
that's that's okay everyone else does
let's fix it right now and that would be
a video hook versus a video intro
wow rob already so much value and i hope
you're seeing you know how all of these
pieces of youtube it's not just like
coming to the channel or coming to the
platform and just making videos there's
like a science behind it and i love how
you had that triangle with the three
pieces that those are so important i
think about um my
uh previous life in you know
digital advertising man when it comes to
anything that social media youtube
specifically is so
visual and when i think about people
that i would work with rob who were
advertisers who went to school for you
know degrees in graphic design all these
pieces it was because it's so critical
for magazines for digital ads for
youtube thumbnails to be visually
stimulating to the point where someone
wants to click and get more you can make
the best video possible but if it's
behind a crappy thumbnail and a bad
title no one's gonna click on it right
rob
yeah i'm right in thinking that think
media has a dedicated uh person for
solely making thumbnails that's right
isn't it you consider it so important
that you have somebody probably um
spending hours deciding whether to use a
bright red or a crimson red well you
know like should should my fonts be in
italic or in bold should uh have it be
on the right side of the screen the left
hand side of the screen that's so
crucial i know obviously resources allow
allow you to do that but i think just
generally speaking people spend
five percent of their time on the
thumbnail when
and we've actually been asking this at
vid iq
for smaller channels is it almost the
case that the thumbnail and the title
are actually more important than the
content because you have such limited
opportunities uh in terms of your reach
to get people to click
um
it's an open for debate and that sounds
ridiculous but you know when you really
start to think about it
yeah especially for smaller creators who
have they've got maybe 1 000 impressions
to play with how crucial is it just to
win the click yeah it really is and yeah
we do you know it started out sean
making all of the thumbnails and that
was really his role for for several
years in the company and then as we were
able to grow now yeah we do we have ian
on our team and he is i mean you could
even see in think media's uh library
where ian came in where he really
started to come in and just really level
up the branding and what the thumbnails
look like and i mean he was he he is a
graphic designer that came from that
background of movie uh posters and from
you know netflix i mean he has a huge
background in digital design and it
matters so much but rob your point about
twi keep it simple keep it simple this
is the youtube made simple show rob and
i love that you brought that point up
because people over complicate these
things they over complicate titles and
they over complicate the uh the
thumbnail of their video so it's so
amazing that you brought the point that
you just gotta make these thumbnails
simple and we'll make sure to link that
video that you recommended as well that
nolan did about what netflix says and
also there's a great book called hook
point so your point about hooks rob
that is so important we are losing
attention people are losing attention
and we want to make sure that you
understand what is a hook what is the
hook of a video and why is it so
important so i'll make sure to link that
resource down below but rob before we
get into the next uh point i want to
just shout out a few people that are
here live that are watching uh maximum
your gauge is here uh gill is here we've
got all things wagner is here
and if you're getting value already from
these points that rob did
rob what should they do they should hit
the like button right
hit that like button yes hit that like
button this one but
down
here yeah i mean i mean nobody nobody
can see the dislike button anywhere and
that you don't get counts from anymore
so it's pointless pressing it exactly
exactly so hit the like button and if
you're not already subscribed to this
channel you're here right now you're on
our think media podcast channel so if
you're not subscribed here make sure
you're subscribed because we have an
amazing podcast episode that's coming up
i'm gonna tell you a little bit more
about it after rob gives one of his
points because it's so aligned for the
next thing that you should watch here on
the channel but rob let's go ahead and
get into your next point which is my
favorite word that i know a lot of
people do not like rob this is a word
that people really struggle with a lot
so tell them what point number four is
it is commit to consistency
usually
when
somebody says consistency on youtube
they default think that it is post x
number of videos uh per week
and while it is that is one of the
aspects of consistency
it's a lot more than that when i do um
channel audits
uh i often when i look at a certain
channel i see they're going in all sorts
of different directions
i'll summarize it by saying okay so your
commitment to consistency for the next
four or five videos might be just making
thumbnails that are really consistent
you know they don't look as if they've
been designed by a different channel
every single time or
you're making a video for the ideal
viewer every single time uh you're
keeping a consistent style and format in
terms of um
the length of a video or
the style of a video
and the reason i'm saying this and you
know as you grow as a creator you can
start to experiment and you know you
should always be experimenting
i'd say 20 of a time but if you're
committing to consistency 80 of the time
on your content in all aspects
what you're doing there is you're
creating a familiarity with your content
and an expectation with your viewers and
if you're meeting those expectations and
satisfying those viewers
every single time then if you're
consistent with that
those
viewers turn into return viewers
and they're going to return to your
content and not just watch one of your
videos but watch multiples of your
videos i'm trying to avoid the word
subscribers because i
personally feel
that while subscribers mean that you hit
certain milestones and you get
rewards and trophies the crucial thing
is that that is just a moment in time
when somebody pressed a red button it is
not a commitment by them to watch future
content it just means that they have
more access to your content but return
viewers actually reflect those who are
starting to align more with your values
and what your
the stories that you're telling or the
education that you're providing and they
want to become more involved in your
values and your passions and then they
may become
super fans uh awesome members of the
community just like everybody watching
right now and then ultimately if you're
trying to turn your channel into a
business and monetize it they may start
investing in your products and services
and that's
generally done through committing to
your own consistency
oh man rob the commitment to consistency
oh where's rob there's rob okay the
commitment to consist i'm down here
pressing all the buttons uh is is so
critical and wow say that one more time
rob because that was a huge unlock the
piece about the subscribers they're just
someone who hit a red button right but
it's the return viewers that really
caught the the um
the uh comments so just say that one
more give a little more depth into that
tell me a little bit more about that so
i'm sure um you've had this situation
where a commenter on a channel has said
hang on why should i pay attention to
you you've got like a million
subscribers but your videos only get 20
000 views or whatever and while that is
true
i think any creator who's gone on the
journey would never
raise that issue or concern because
subscribers that term are very fickle
they're pressing a red button
but once they've pressed that red button
it is so important what you show that
subscriber or that viewer next because
if the next video doesn't align with the
values and expectations that you've set
in previous videos it doesn't matter if
you're subscribed but we're not going to
click on the next video and because
subscribers never expire
you know if you haven't watched a video
for
30 days it doesn't mean that youtube's
automatically going to unsubscribe you
but now that's actually bringing up an
idea in my head maybe i should propose
that to youtube that's a really
interesting fault though anyway before i
get sidetracked
think of it from this point of view
let's say
um
somebody watched a one of your videos
last week
that viewer is more likely to see
your next video recommended in home or
suggested or elsewhere than somebody who
subscribed to your channel
18 months ago and hasn't watched any of
your content since it says return
viewers who are actually feeding
data into your channel in terms of
clicks and watch time and comments that
are far more viable than subscribers
unfortunately with the business that
we're in in terms of youtube education
many people start their youtube journeys
they subscribe they get frustrated and
they decide to stop creating content so
they are i guess effectively a dead
subscriber
so yeah i i'm still on this sort of
semis crusade to try and educate people
that while
subscribers are crucial for unlocks
at least up until the first thousand
subscribers it's really nourishing
return viewers
and making sure that they're satisfied
and they continue to watch your content
yeah when we bring it back to the
commitment for consistency it's not
necessarily consistency to gain
subscribers then right rob it's
consistency for the return viewer you
want to keep giving them content that is
helpful that is um that is answering
questions that they have that is helping
them with whatever it is whether it be
plumbing or baking or
bike riding whatever your topic is
you're committing to consistency for the
people who really have already raised
their hand right like it's not it is
about gaining more but really it's so
much about consistency for you as a
content creator and consistency to show
up so why do youtube channels fail
because people just stop showing up i
mean think about rob if we were friends
and you and i and we were always on the
phone we're video chatting we're doing
all those things and then all of a
sudden rob you just ghost me well then i
wouldn't want to come back right so it's
that same idea we're just pulling it
into the platform so uh rob number one
was that a channel only fails when the
content creator quits i loved that that
you brought up mr beast and just how
he's been at this for so long number two
was the lack of focus we got to stay
focused we got to know what we're doing
this for why we're doing it and how
we're going to do it three is the front
load your efforts meaning that your
title your thumbnail and your hook
really really matter number four commit
to consistency let's jump into number
five rob and then we're gonna get into
some q and a for the people that are
here live for today
okay so i'm gonna leave myself a little
bit of an out here i do need to leave in
a tiny margin for error but
99.9 of a time
it's not
youtube's fault that your channel is
failing
people often fail to take accountability
for their channels they just assume that
youtube is against them
and we've seen this many times
on uh vid iq comments where somebody
will say i've done everything you've
said
in your youtube education and my channel
isn't growing and then we'll take a
cursory glance at their channel and
within two seconds
we've seen that they've got a lack of
focus and their thumbnails just aren't
that clickable yet
now i want to give you a bit of a
personal story as we were kind of
briefly mentioning earlier on
um right now the vid iq channel
is down in terms of views around about
25 to 30 from where we were uh last
quarter uh so we we tend to do like two
million views a month and we're down at
like 1.6 million views right now now the
reason for this is because search
traffic is down
uh less people are searching for how to
get more views how to get more
subscribers so on and so forth and this
is down to and i think you mentioned
this earlier this is down to seasonality
changes in the sense that
yes people go back to school
but it's just a general feeling that at
least in the northern hemisphere that
where coming up to the the holiday
season people are just generally busier
with life be work education
uh
you know it's getting darker at night
and people perhaps they're winding down
towards the end of the year or they're
just busy with life and so maybe youtube
the side hustle takes a bit of a back
seat
but
if i just left it there and said okay
well i'll wait until the search traffic
builds up again
i'm using that as an excuse i'm not
taking accountability for what vidiq
could potentially do to improve that and
that is
i think as a channel in the past we've
relied too much on search
one-time viewers
so what we need to do as a channel is
satisfy those viewers more so that they
um they return to our content and we do
that through the things that we've
talked about earlier on you know better
thumbnails better titles better video
hooks a more engaging content more
personable content more relatable
content trying to be more of a friend
to our audience
we need to get those viewers
to the end of our videos to send them
off to more of our content through end
screens so you don't just have one-time
views you have session watch time
so what i what i'm doing right now is
i'm taking like personable personal
accountability for this yes at the
moment search may be down so what i'm
really focusing on is increasing the
audience view duration uh after the
first 30 seconds i'm trying to get that
above 70
so that the hook is really powerful i'm
trying to increase click through rate on
the end screens because
up until a couple of months ago our end
screen click-through rate was a shocking
two percent because i just neglected
that area of our content now i'm really
starting to think about how to direct
our views onto more of our content
end screen click-through rates have
multiplied by a factor of five i think
we're by about 12 12 or 14 click-through
rate
so
i'm not blaming youtube for the fact
that our views are down i am holding
myself accountable
and learning and attempting to become a
better creator
for that now yeah there are sometimes
weird anomalies and circumstances where
all of a sudden
it feels like youtube has flicked a
switch and your channel's being shadow
banned and all of a sudden your views
are down and that is where maybe you
need to contact youtube and investigate
why but usually when there's a gradual
increase or decrease in your data your
views your subscribers there is usually
something behind that story and that's
where you have to say to yourself okay i
need to find out what this is because
this can't just be youtube
this there must be a reason for this
whether my audience isn't interested in
my content anymore this topic isn't
interesting anymore because it was a
trending topic what is the reason how
can i adapt remember what i said earlier
create
learn adapt create
repeat
and repeat there we go i was like
and repeat that's exactly right rob well
man five amazing topics as to why
youtube channels fail i want to know
what your aha moment was from today's uh
training with rob from vidiq and rob
right now you guys have a 30-day free
trial of vid iq plan at think at
vidiq.com forward slash think what do
they get when they go and get the free
plan rob oh what what don't you get uh
there is so much uh
vid iq we've been building our tools now
for
uh
i think i think it became a chrome
extension like in 2013
and a lot of the tools that we have are
still there um but you know if i was to
go back from
our most recent tools backwards uh we
introduced the daily ideas tool a couple
of months ago whereby once you start
publishing content on your channel vidiq
will offer you up to 50 daily ideas so
that's a thousand a thousand plus day
ideas
every single month
and
even if you just take like one or two
percent of those ideas and transform it
into video content that will keep you
going for years on youtube
we've also got our channel audit tool
which is kind of a complement to the
youtube studio data we'll try and break
down certain things in terms of what's
performing really well on your channel
right now what other channels are
suggesting content to your videos and
how you can leverage them and then we've
got keyword research i mean one of the
things that i just love i don't know
about you however but since i installed
vid iq
youtube kind of feels uh naked if i
haven't got all of the um the little
stats everywhere here there and
everywhere it's like if i log into
somebody else's computer i'm thinking
hang on why can't i see the video
scorecard oh that's not youtube that's
actually vid iq
so in terms of the 30 day free trial you
get access to
all of our tools
with
no barriers no padlocks or anything and
also our vid iq academy as well where we
do lots of learnings and teachings where
you know on a youtube video you usually
spend no more than 20 minutes on a topic
we go into three hours
on topics like i think there's a
there's a 30 video
how to start your youtube channel over
30 days uh learning academy which is a
one of our flagship courses and has been
for a couple of years now i love it and
i love it iq so much it helps me
in all of the content creation that
we're doing and that video ideas was a
game changer i mean you're doing the
work for us in that respect of just
giving us the ideas that people want so
make sure you check that out if you
don't already have vidiq go to vidiq.com
forward slash think now we're going to
get into q a real quick you can drop
your aha moment from today's training
with rob in the comments if you're
watching live or if you're on the replay
make sure to drop your aha there i love
to go back in the comments read through
those and see what value you're getting
from trainings just like this and if
you're not already subscribed to our
actual podcast you don't want to miss
tomorrow's episode because we're diving
into how to deal with toxic people that
don't support you on youtube do you feel
like maybe you're failing on youtube
because no one in your life really
supports what you're trying to create i
think you'll be surprised at our answer
that we have for that so make sure you
subscribe to this channel so you can
listen to tomorrow's podcast or if you
go anywhere that podcasts are where you
can listen to them are like apple and
spotify
you can get tomorrow's episode as well
as i think we're almost to 100 over 100
episodes on the podcast as well so make
sure you subscribe for that tomorrow and
rob we're going to jump into some q and
a and we actually had a super chat that
came in while you were talking so i want
to say thank you for the super chat
super chat i want like a super chat like
do you have um do you have audio uh like
an audio face where you can make fun
sounds sean just got one and i'm jealous
now i feel like i need one i can do this
there we go there we go sound effects
yeah
i love that i love that so here's the
one uh that we got for the super chat
how important is it to maximize current
trends as in time frame of 24 hours 12
hours um etc now we one of the ways that
we say you can dominate on youtube is by
trend surfing which just means that if
there's a trend in your niche that you
can talk about maybe there's a new
product that's out or maybe something in
the in our um like a cultural trend is
happening if you can jump on that trend
as soon as possible you can actually
start to
get views because people are interested
in whatever that thing is so for us that
would be like a new camera that drops a
new lens that drops um when our friend
pat flynn released the switch pod doing
a video on that like culturally in our
niche um it's really important that you
jump on those trends but here's what i
don't like rob is sometimes people will
see a trend and they'll just sit on the
trend and they'll wait on the trend and
then they make a video about the trend
you're like oh trends don't work you got
to hit the trend when the trend is
happening right rob
yeah
one of the things we pride ourselves on
vid iq is bringing a creator's
um
viewpoint and opinion to youtube updates
so examples of this recently have been
community tab been lowered to 500
subscribers as a requirement uh youtube
hiding public dislikes
um
youtube shorts monetization uh whenever
i see a new story like that that is a
trend within youtube education so we
jump on it as quickly as possible and i
think we
i think we've got to a point now where
people almost come to vidiq for that for
that
non youtube polished up uh press release
on a topic but yeah
trend surfing
um
is a shortcut to massive channel growth
but because of that and because so many
creators are aware of that it is
extremely competitive
so being one of the first obviously is
absolutely critical but also
finding a unique angle to it
or really nailing down on one specific
point of that trend um
an example in my past is when um
apple uh we're releasing iphones and
it's very difficult to record the screen
so you know in new ios releases people
are really excited about the new camera
features uh how the home screen is going
to change but i saw that one little
thing about how to record your phone
or your ipad which used to be very
difficult and i focused on that and i
built up an audience for that very
particular thing you know
talking about that ideal viewer the
ideal viewer being i want to record
using my iphone and i ipod and i can't
do it and i told people how to do it
multiple times
the other thing also to
appreciate is how can
you make it
so that your viewers don't just feel as
if you're jumping on a trend for the
sake of it you're actually turning that
trend into something that's culturally
relevant uh for you and your audience
for example
animation channels are maybe turning a
story into a quirky animation that not
only includes a story but also maybe
some of their characters or when
somebody's crafting something they're
building maybe an iron man helmet but
because they're a woodcrafter they're
doing the uh you know
an antique version of it or in some
fashion it's how can you make something
that's
culturally relevant to
millions of people
really relevant to your corner of
youtube
yep and trends matter i mean it really
does and and even thinking about how um
uh thinking about like nolan did that
trend on netflix netflix is kind of just
a cultural thing that's happening might
as well pull it in and make it relevant
to what you're actually doing i love
that uh you said too rob dominate that's
what you want to do you want to like
keep making videos around that same
topic so you can dominate on that trend
and become the go-to person for that i'm
gonna take a sip of my apple cider real
quick rob because it's thanksgiving week
here in the us
uh and tony the producer is gonna put
another question on the screen for us
oh it's a surprise is it a mission
surprise questions what would you say
are three signs you need to pivot your
channel rob
okay
so i think the first thing would be a um
reduction in return view is because that
means your
core audience
your sticky audience of people who like
your content the most uh it's not
resonating with them as much that would
be the first thing and i'm gonna hand it
over to heather for the second point
while i think of the third point i know
i was like i'm gonna pass this one to
rob because maybe he has something right
away
all right so what would you say are the
three signs so my first thing in
pivoting your channel is looking at if
you are consistently making content on a
certain topic and you're not seeing uh
that that topic is one that's that's
popping off right that that one is going
but maybe you made a video in the past
we see this a lot they'll make that one
video and they're like yeah that was fun
but i'm gonna make top videos on this
and then we look at their channel and
i'm like no this is the topic you should
make videos on this is showing what your
audience wants so i think one of the
three signs is is what are your
analytics saying are you actually in
your analytics seeing
what videos your audience wants and what
types of videos you should be creating
you might want to create whatever video
you want but if you're really at this
because you want to grow a youtube
channel that can get monetized that can
create a business that can give you
financial freedom and time freedom and
allow you to be creative i mean that's
big picture things but you have to start
with actually like serving what people
want i think about this is like when i
go to a restaurant
i want what's on the menu i'm not at the
restaurant because i'm like you know
what i think i want this random thing no
i am at this restaurant because i want
to eat this type of food and so what
dishes are you serving up to your
audience and what dishes are they coming
back for over and over again if you've
got something on your menu that all of a
sudden is like everyone's coming in and
ordering that chicken salad thing then
you want to make more chicken salads
because it'll help your your channel
grow and then you can start talking
about more topics than you that than
just that one thing
rob number three yeah okay i've had a
little time to digest the question
i think it comes back to the the concept
of seasonality in the sense that it
might not necessarily be that your
channel is is dying and you need to
pivot it's a case of this time of year
it means that your audience
isn't really it doesn't have like for
example i assume that you're some sort
of outdoors uh channel so maybe as we
move into the winter months
people are thinking about that but what
they may be thinking about is what
they're gonna buy and purchase during
black friday
to prepare for going outdoors in the
spring so that might be something to
potentially consider in terms of
seasonality but if you've gone through
maybe
a year two years and the channel seems
to be down and it seems like it's
fundamentally
a shift is is required in your channel
as a whole
but if it's just seasonality then it's
just maybe that the focus on the
particular topics that you need to
realign
for the time of year
really really great rob i want to shout
out a few people that are here live
we're going to get to one more question
today and then we are going to head off
to the next stream we have er the next
uh um video we have and make sure you
subscribe so you can watch the podcast
tomorrow last question on the screen is
all right
cruise
cruise vids perform best on my travel
channel but can't afford to cruise all
the time should i just do travel tips
and tricks because cruising
between cruising even though views are
way less comparatively i got through
that question rob i should read it one
more time but understand the purpose is
that this person does cruise videos
can't afford cruising all the time
neither can i i want the life where i
can rob that's actually what i'm working
for is the life where i can cruise all
the time uh
but um what types of videos should they
do between tips and tricks videos uh
what types of things would you recommend
to someone with a channel like all
things wagner
i would imagine uh oh frozen
there you are you're back i i would
imagine that you are not alone in this
struggle in that you um can only do uh
the thing that you're talking about
maybe
one or two times a year uh
i i guess a crossover channel might be
um
somebody who covers the um theme parks
there's a lot of channels that do like
disney theme parks and orlando theme
parks but they they only get to go maybe
two or three times a year so i think
doing research on what these other
channels are up to when they're not
actually
on the activity and you're right in the
terms of it's probably about the tips
and tricks in planning and preparing uh
for
these uh adventures
i would also think that if you are
your channel's probably based on your
experiences and your stories on the
cruise so i think making the content
more personable more relatable so that
even when you're not on a cruise people
want to come back and watch our contents
for you
uh
that's some that's something that's very
difficult uh that's kind of the
crossover from making people come for
your content and then falling in love
with you so that they keep watching even
if the content isn't necessarily aligned
uh with
their values uh anymore so i think
research i think i think there is i
think there's definitely channels in
your same space that have that same
issue
and
they've hopefully the the successful
channels have figured out how to do
a crossover between on a cruise or or
not on a cruise planning and preparing
for the next one
yeah a couple more tips i would give too
especially if you're in the travel niche
like this
is that um
there are uh you are already probably
really good at finding deals on cruises
like if you've been a cruiser you
already know where to go what websites
to look at what forums to read all of
those pieces are actually videos that
you can create so you could even do a
video once a week about the best cruise
deals
in december the best cruise deals in
november and all you're doing is just
sourcing screen sharing you could use a
software like we're using here which is
stream yard you can record the video or
you could go live and you could just
share screens of different programs and
then here's this because my brain always
goes business rob
you can sign up as affiliates for all
for all of these websites they have
different types of affiliates so if
someone books a cruise through a travel
website that has an affiliate
for that and they book that cruise that
you recommended with your link you get
some money for someone booking a cruise
so you don't even necessarily have to be
on a cruise
you can also think about ways that you
can help other beginner cruisers um my
mom actually is disabled and so cruising
was the way for her to be able to see
the world there's a whole avenue of of
um of things like that like what are the
accessibilities on the cruise ships uh
which types of cabins should families of
four get like look at the questions that
people are actually typing into the
search bar you can go to vidiq.com
forward slash think and you can see the
ideas that will probably pop up when you
type this in my brain's going crazy rob
i'm like this person could become the
cruising person you could interview
other people that maybe they went on
their 100th cruise and they're also a
website or they're also a blog or
they're also a youtube channel you can
interview them on their experience
there's so many ways that you can create
videos don't get yourself in a box of
thinking that one way of video is the
only way of video there are countless
ways that you can create content on the
platform and it's just deciding that
you're going to be open you you want to
create this channel you want to help and
serve other people and try and figure
out these ways that you can do these
tips and tricks videos between the
cruising and here's a big tip
when you go on your cruise before you
leave what are the 10 video ideas you're
gonna do when you get back what b-roll
do you need like i do this when i travel
rob i like write down what what
should i be getting photos of my family
in a certain way so i can do like
instagram swipe ups should i be
recording b-roll with the new camera
that we're trying to test out that we're
going to do a video on in three weeks
like i'm thinking about these things
these are tips that you could use when
you go on your next cruise to be able to
have a plethora of b-roll or examples or
video ideas before you even step a foot
on the ship yeah i was just going to add
there as well i think just capturing far
much more content than you think you
need so that you can potentially
repurpose that content uh the idea i was
thinking of is let's say once you've
been on five cruises which i assume you
probably have at this point you could
then say right we can do a connecting
piece of content where we review the
best restaurants on each of these
cruises and so yes you are repurposing
content but you're doing it with an
entirely different direction style and
voice that's going to keep you through
those lean months when you fight you
know you're looking for the next deal
for the next cruise yeah and also last
tip because i love these kind of
questions are um researcher competition
what are the five to ten other channels
that are doing cruise type content what
when you go to their best performing
videos what are those topics because
that's showing you exactly your audience
and what they like to uh what content
they like and here's the thing if it's a
bigger channel and i mean bigger like
over maybe 10 000 they probably aren't
able to get to all their comments there
are questions and video ideas in those
comments that you can pull from as a
supportive channel to the bigger channel
that's a huge idea where it's like i
don't know what to do do videos that
people are asking specific questions
well rob i want to thank you so much for
being on today thank you for being a
part of what we're doing here at think
media where can people find you rob
online
well um a few years ago i was melted
down into my constituent part so i no
longer have any um personal
um
internet handles or anything i'm just at
vid iq i'm i'm an essence i i am a being
a vid iq so if you send a tweet or a
message to vidiq chances are i will see
it and chances are i will be the ones
responding to it so at vidiq
amazing well thank you so much rob for
being on today you can get your free
trial of vid iq over at
vidiq.com forward slash think and make
sure that you subscribe to this channel
so you can get all of our content that
we have coming up in the future i want
to thank you for being a part of the
think media family thank you for being
on the live stream if you are live today
or for watching this on the replay and
commenting in the comments you can tap
or touch the screen to watch the next
video here on the youtube made simple
show and we'll catch you in the next
video bye fam